going to war in 1917 was very much a
different thing for the united states
most americans thought of the atlantic
not so much as a highway but rather as a
moat and it kept us separated from
wars that happened overseas and here we
were being dragged into this conflict
but it was a transformational moment in
american history our first overseas
adventure spanish-american war
notwithstanding with the battle in the
philippine islands so it was very much a
transitional moment for the united
united states to go overseas and
participate in the first world war the
united states really did have world war
one in a sense as its coming out party
onto the world stage and so the country
that comes out of the war in 1918 is
very different than the one that started
the war in 1917.
world war one began on july 28 1914
awakening europe from a generation of
restless peace
and bringing mechanized destruction and
mass casualty at unprecedented levels
still
nearly three years passed before
american president woodrow wilson asked
congress for a declaration of war
against germany
three years of trench warfare left
europe exhausted
the arrival of american expeditionary
forces in june 1917 would tip the
balance
this was the coming out of american
power on the world stage
what would the war's legacy be for
america
and for the world
the effort required to mobilize the us
army to fight a major war was something
that had never really taken place
in american history the civil war
obviously required a great deal of
mobilization but that's not an
industrial war in the same way that
world war one is and it's not an
overseas war
so the process of taking a u.s army
which essentially was
a constabulary force it's an imperial
police force and turning it into a mass
army to fight modern warfare was an
enormous transformation it required
conscription it required training up an
officer corps almost from scratch and
war has a way of
rapidly accelerating social change so
that the war to fight that war we had to
do all kinds of things as a country that
broke precedent you know
whether it was putting women in
factories because there were so many men
overseas in arming african-american
soldiers and creating african-american
regiments uh essentially the federal
government to a degree taking over the
economy uh you know the industrial
economy in a way that was just
unthinkable but it's wartime and to
think about what's required to bring
these american troops to maturity i
think the simplest way to do it is to
look at a calendar the united states
enters the war in april 1917 and it's
really a full year before american
troops see combat
when the americans began to arrive in
1918 uh on the western front they came
in piecemeal a million men didn't show
up all at once they came in a bit at a
time and of course the instinct of the
western allies to throw them into the
line where they were needed most so that
they'd be spread out all across the
front at this point in the war
the british and the french are so short
on manpower the war has been so draining
that they desperately need young men
that they can use to fill up their
battalions and their divisions and
americans arrive and they really want to
use that manpower as quickly as they can
wilson's choice of pershing as the man
who's going to be leading the american
expeditionary force was central in lots
of ways certainly then and now americans
are very leery of the thought that
non-americans are going to be telling
american soldiers what to do but
pershing took that even further he was
adamant throughout the war that wherever
possible americans are going to fight
under american command he wanted to make
clear that this is an american force so
that america has its own voice in the
peace settlement that's going to come at
the end of the war
the europeans had to accommodate that
because their need for american manpower
was so great
but the americans had to put up a fight
to get that position get their section
of the line rather than being parceled
out along the front
even once this army was built
british and french observers remarked
that american soldiers are remarkably
brave and they're remarkably well fed
and in really good shape
but they're overly enthusiastic they
don't have a sense of what they're up
against and so american soldiers
take horrific losses in their first
engagements in europe and part of it is
simple lack of institutional experience
in what trench warfare is like and how
to fight it
[Music]
in the spring of 1918 the germans are
taking troops that had been fighting the
russians but have been released by the
russian revolution and turning those
troops against the british and the
french on the western front and the
germans almost win the war um the
british are talking about the
possibility of evacuating british troops
from continental europe
so it seems as though victory is
extremely close
but the germans exhaust their last
resources of supplies and manpower and
trying to do this and they simply can't
sustain it and so from that time on the
germans are kind of looking
for a way out and then the americans
arrive and the numbers shift in the
wrong direction for them so that the
americans in effect arrived with just
enough strength but at just the right
time to tip that balance which was
already teetering over in the direction
of the allies
there are hundreds of thousands of
american troops streaming into france
every month and the germans simply can't
hold up the german army begins to
disintegrate
in august and september of 1918 and the
germans decide that they have no choice
but to ask for peace
they ask for peace on woodrow wilson's
terms but they decide they have to ask
for peace
on january 8 1918
president wilson delivered a speech on
war aims and peace terms that he
believed could end the war
known today as the 14 points wilson
called for arms reduction free trade
freedom of the seas
germany's return to france of alsace
lorraine
peace in the balkans
creation of a polish state
breakup of the ottoman empire and
negotiated sovereignty in all colonial
territories
most dear to wilson was formation of a
general association of nations the
league of nations to enforce peace
political independence and territorial
integrity
so the 14 points are really central to
understanding the peace process at the
end of the first world war
but i think they need to be seen in
context
and part of the context predates the 14
points the russian revolution had taken
place in 1917 uh and the communists the
bolshevik party under vladimir lenin
take power in um november 1917.
and lenin calls for a piece as well um
an immediate piece an immediate
ceasefire and so to some degree wilson
is responding to the bolshevik challenge
the bolsheviks are calling for immediate
peace
what do the allies have to say in
response and so wilson articulates a
vision that's not nearly as radical as
lenin's but tries in some ways to
capture some of the sense of the need
for justice um when the war is settled
now to be frank about it the british and
the french see wilson's 14 points as to
a large degree naive wilson's 14 points
uh
were the subject of uh mocking comments
in in europe i mean he was an academic
came out of princeton university
not a long history of experience in
international relations
and a little bit of a not more more than
a little bit a great deal of an idealist
so that when he comes out with these
high-minded principles
the europeans were
were skeptical of that and they they
have some logic behind that um it's very
easy for wilson to talk about a piece
that is fair and just to all parties
when the united states has not been
fighting very long and has not lost very
many lives the british and the french
have been fighting for a very long time
and have seen a lot of young men killed
and it's much harder for british and
french political leaders and the british
and french publics to embrace a piece of
justice and understanding when so much
blood has been shed
the problem was that the allies the
western allies the british and french
needed the americans so badly needed
their strength their numbers their money
as much as anything else so they
couldn't openly make fun of things
wilson said because they desperately
needed wilson it did however resonate in
the minds of not only americans but i
think individuals overseas as well
who thought well here at last here is
something to fight for maybe some good
can come out of this conflict after all
when we get to november 1918 and the
armistice there is a question about
whether the germans can fight and one of
the things that the allies do is they do
try to make it impossible for germany to
continue its resistance um the allies
have seized territory on the far on the
eastern bank of the rhine river they've
made it so that if germany starts
fighting again the germans are going to
have very serious trouble making this
happen it'll be fought on german soil
the german army will have much less
equipment than it had before um
essentially the allies have made it so
that when the treaty of versailles
presented to the germans the germans
have no choice but to accept it they
cannot meaningfully resist anymore it
wasn't clear in november 1918 that the
german army could no longer fight it
still had three million men in arms and
it thought that it was coming to terms
on the basis of the 14 points whereas at
the end of world war ii germany lay
absolutely prostrate and defeated at the
end of world war one the fighting
finished at a time when at least
potentially the conflict could have gone
on for a lot longer because germany was
still able to mobilize a lot of
resources if germany had dragged on its
resistance for another six months the
world would have been a different place
german defeat would have been much more
clear the war would have ended up on
german soil um as when the war ended
essentially the war still being fought
in belgium and france not in germany
the role of the united states would have
been that much much greater
on the other hand uh it seems to me that
if the germans say we're tired of
fighting please stop
um
you're talking about hundreds of
thousands of young lives are going to be
lost simply for purposes of extending a
war that the germans have admitted is
over and that they've been beaten um and
so it's tough to imagine circumstances
under which the allies say
we don't want to take a ceasefire we
don't want to accept an armistice let's
keep fighting and killing more young men
just so we can prove a political point
but since one of the conditions of the
armistice was that the germans had to
back away from their defensive lines had
to give up their fleet surrender their
fleet to the british
who took it up to scapa flow
the germans were effectively disarmed so
the negotiations that were to follow the
ordinance were entirely one-sided the
germans not even invited to participate
in the conversations at versailles
the armistice ending fighting was signed
at 5 10 in the morning on november 11
1918 amid exhaustion of the front and
celebration at home
the war's conclusion did not mean the
commencement of peace
some 320 americans died on the last day
of fighting and in u.s elections six
days earlier
americans rejected the democrat wilson's
pleas to sustain me with undivided minds
republicans won majorities in both
senate and house
trouble beckoned
exuberant mood here in america when the
war ended by then more than a million
american soldiers were involved in the
fighting and the casualty rate among
them was very high more than a thousand
a week so for huge numbers of american
families who've got young men husbands
and brothers and and sons in the
fighting a sense of relief that their
their men folk would live and i think
also um
an exuberant sense of realizing that
america really was now a world power but
its intervention in the war had helped
bring it to a successful conclusion much
earlier than it otherwise been expected
president wilson actually left the
united states and went to paris to join
in the negotiations never before had a
sitting president gone off to
participate in treaty making of this
kind
one of the things that's very clear is
that wilson gets to europe and is hailed
as a hero
he's adored by the european masses
i think woodrow wilson saw himself as
the savior of mankind and i that's not
much of an exaggeration he believed that
if he went personally to paris he would
be the one who would keep these people
from taking advantages of of a defeated
foe so that it was not a piece of
victory and defeat it was a peace that
would last forever the war to end all
wars i think he took
that responsibility seriously it turned
out that he wasn't really very good at
it and that he was outwitted by his
cynical english and french
contemporaries so there was plenty of
hope but it was it wasn't it wasn't
really fulfilled by what happened
ultimately very quickly the real
differences and priorities between the
us on the one side and britain and
france and the other become apparent
they are such different types it's not
uh there's no meaning of the mind there
i mean a hard-bitten politician
and an
idealistic academic
trying to work out a deal wilson thought
he had the moral high ground
lloyd george and clemenceau of course
had
uh the reality of the politics behind
them
i think hindsight suggests he would have
had a greater influence if he'd stayed
away from paris as an ominous greece in
the distance whose reputation was such
that instead of getting involved in the
the horse trading that took place in the
mirrored halls at versailles he could
instead exercise his influence from a
distance and perhaps have an even
greater impact because in the end he did
get drawn into the horse trading and
that
that damaged not only uh the world's
view of who wilson was and the role that
he played but i think it damaged
wilson's perception of who he was and
the role he was destined to play in his
own mind
there is certainly in the short run
euphoria at america's triumphal entrance
onto the world stage but what's striking
is how quickly that turns
president wilson on bending ran into
senate foreign relations committee
chairman henry cabot lodge unyielding
the result a triumph of stony pragmatism
in the republican senate and the tragedy
of idealism in global diplomacy
president wilson took his campaign for
the league of nations and versailles
treaty directly to the american people
in an 8 000 mile cross-country train
tour that began hopefully
and ended in exhaustion with the stroke
that incapacitated him for the rest of
his presidency and life
europe was left with the league of
nations it didn't believe in
and america never joined nor ratified
the peace treaty
and the american mood turns from
triumphant american accomplishments to
bitterness and cynicism about
how little american sacrifice is
actually achieved
and this again is a case where i think
wilson's own rhetoric undoes him in that
he's talked about a world a war to make
the world safer democracy a war to end
war
and it seems as though it's all just
become
the same old dirty game of european
politics wilson is very much a tragic
figure he went to europe believing he
could save the world he came back from
europe
disappointed that he had to trade away
so many things but he did get the league
that was the thing that mattered if he
could get the league and people would
take it seriously it could prevent a
second world war and he brought that
back to america having sacrificed so
much to get it and the country said no
and insisted on changes but wilson being
that idealist that he was would accept
no changes no modifications no revisions
take it or leave it and so of course in
the end it failed of ratification very
narrowly i mean it did have a majority
of support but not a two-thirds majority
required to confirm and so
the great tragedy of his subsequent
illness going on the road trying to sell
it to american people that contributed
to his
decline in health and he ended his days
in the white house as sadly as it's
possible
and that mood of disgust bitterness
alienation resentment of american
sacrifice for the benefit of europeans
is one of the things that makes
isolationism so powerful in the 1920s
and 1930s in this country
and if you look actually for the years
the months and years after world war one
they are phenomenally fractious
tumultuous times it's the greatest
strike wave in american history is 1919
there are you know police strikes
there's
terrorist bombings it's it's a really
really tumultuous time
[Music]
it's almost exclusively in hindsight
that we look back and now see world war
one and world war ii as bookends of a
single event that the 20 years peace the
20 years armistice if you would between
1919 and 1939 the two decades that
europe and the world took a deep breath
and then went at it again and and in
that hindsight it's possible see to see
the seeds of the second world war being
sown the question of the link between
world war one and world war ii is a very
deep and fraught one for historians we
argue about that a lot um certainly
there are many who would see a very
clear line between the treaty versailles
and the resentment it creates in germany
and
hitler's rise to power and that's
undeniable the victorious allies imposed
on germany
a peace treaty far harsher than they'd
anticipated which didn't really live up
to the spirit of the 14 points the
demand for reparations the insistence
that germany must pay for the damage it
caused and in order to justify the
reparations saddling germany with the
responsibility of having initiated the
war and that in turn led to the german
perception that they'd been tricked and
betrayed
the so-called stab in the back theory
which made it very difficult for the
weimar republic ever to gain legitimacy
and in turn made it relatively more easy
for hitler to rise to power there's very
definitely an opportunity lost weimar
germany could have survived we made it
almost impossible for it to be
successful by terms of the
economic response you know the the debts
that they were required to pay the
reparations as well as the debts
and we so undermined their chance to try
democracy as the title of a famous book
has it
that that experiment was almost doomed
from the beginning in the german
elections before the great depression
the nazi party gets two percent of the
vote
hitler's party before the great
depression is a bunch of obscure cranks
that nobody pays any attention to
it's only the great depression that
takes hitler from being this minor
figure on the far right and catapults
him to the center of german politics and
that of course spawned the fascist and
extremist views
that took over germany again
in the night early 1930s and led to
the outbreak of war in 1939 so
looking back on it it's easy to see how
those steps were taken i think it's much
harder for those living at the time to
see oh we are making a stupid mistake by
insisting on getting
every ounce of retribution out of this
piece from our enemy
world war one military and civilian
casualties totaled 40 million
a generation of british french and
german men was lost
the united states emerged economically
and militarily dominant but
diplomatically isolated
world war one did not end all wars
some believe its legacy is the lost
peace leading to world war ii
[Music]
so
[Music]
you